r
monte dans la tour du parlement
pour huiler le mécanisme
de l'horloge.
- Cette l'apporter chez nous. Ee
ici, à l'Assemblée nationale.
♪ ♪ ♪
- Même s'il règle le cadran au
♪ ♪ ♪- Moi, c'est la première fs
que je voyais ça, là.
- ... il a l'impression
que le temps s a a arrêté
durant la pandémie.
Ici, tout
Personne dans les couloirs,
aucun teteteur ni employé,
pas même un député pour
fa
parlementaires.
DRDRDRÉ VIGER, horloger
du parlement de Québec
comprendre le temps,
comment ststst important
à l'Assemblée nationale.
FRANÇOIS LEGAULT,
- J'ai pris la décision de
rmrmrmer toutes les entreprises
et tous les commerces.
(applaudissements)
- Rien ne laissait présager
que François Legault auraitesess
de l'histoire du Québec.
Au pouvoir pour la première
fois, la CAQ hérite de surplusle
dollars qui lui permettent
de réduire la taxe scolaire,
de bonifier les allocationsesesr
le tarif unique dans
les garderies et la gratuité
de la fécondation in vitro- - -.
- Pourtant, sa positionr r r r :
il veut réduire le seuilueueuel
à 40 000 nouveaux arrivants,
qui doivent maintena
un test des valeurs québécoises.
Les dossiers d 0 0 000 d'entre
eux seront éliminés pour
permettre
de repartir le proccessus
sur devevevelles bases.
SIMON JOLIN-BARRETTE,
- On est capable au Québec
importante comme celle-là.- Le e
quand la loi sur la laïcité
de l'État est déposée.sisisisise
de Justice Femme
- Le gouvernement fait
délibérément le choix de
discriminer les Québécoises
- La loi interdit le port
de signes religieux pour
les enseignants, les agents
de la paix, les juges et
les procureurs de n n n n n n ns
religieux pour personne!
- Pour évileleles contestations
judiciaires, le gouvernement
recourt à la clause dérogatoire,
ceisisisisisisisisisisisisisisi.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,prprpremier minia
- L'utilisation de la clause
nonobstant ne devrait être fait.
- Québec utilisera cette clause
uxuxux fois plutôt qu'une.
- Bonjour! Can I help you?
sa réforme de la loi 101.
- Loi sur la langue officielle
et commune du Québec
(applaudissements)glglglglglglgt
que le Parti libéral ne
les défend pas, ce qui force
la cheffe Dominique Angladee e .
DOMINIQUE ANGLADE, cheffe du PLQ
- C'est aller à la rencontre
des gens.
progressiste dérange. Couronnée
sans course à la direction
après le désistement de
son seul adversaire, elle veut
ses distances de Philippe
Couillard et Jean Char
- J'ai jamais dit que
ce serait facile, non plus,
- Aujourd'hui,
je veux fair a a appel,
un appel à la solidarité.
- Et pendant ce temps,
toute la visibilité.
rgrgrgence sanitaire,
renouvelée une centaine de fois
des pouvoirs exceptionnels.- One
des décisions difficiles.
de Noël, le passeport vaccinal,
les couvre-feux, la fermeture
des salles de spectacle,
des écoles.
- J'aurais aimé rester à l'école
parce
j'ai une super prof.
- Restez chez vous,
- Les problèmes de santé menta
se gèrent difficilement.
obligatoire des travailleurs
de la santé, sur la taxe
rien de tout ça n'esrerere que
l'hécatombe du CHSLD Herron.blb♪
- Aujourd'hui,
le Québec se souvient.
- On compte plus de
16 000 décès au
- Ne sommes-nous pas rendus à
déclencher une enquête publique?
- Ça
une commission d'enquête.
- Tu peux pas rien cacher.
- François Legault a toujours
exclut l'enquête publi d d d d e
à la santé, de la vérificatrice
générale et de la protectrice
du citoyen.
- Je pense que Christian
cassante.
- Devant le quasi-ndndndrement
du réseau, il écarte Danielle
McCann pour Christian Dubé, dont
Trouver un médecin de famille
pour chaQuQuQuébécois,
couper 1 milliard de dollars
dans le salaire des médecins
le temps supplémentaire
lililigatoire des infirmières
s'avèrent irréalisables.
CHRISTIAN DUBÉ, ministre San S c
- Les crises permettent aux
organisations de se repenser.
- Même si la campagne
de vaccination est un succès,
elle ne sauvera pas osososte
du Dr Horacio Arruda.
- Le mieux, c'
de l'eau et du savon.
- Véritabldededette au début
de la pandémie avec sa candeur
et s
le premier ministre doit
d d départir; ses décisions
sont fortement critiquées.
national de santé publique du Qc
- J'ai des menaces de mort.
Je reçois des courriels
injurieux tous les jous s s s ss
les partis sont aussi menacés.
La sécurité est rehaussée.
- C'est important
qu'on soit- De parler à l'uniss.
- Par solidarité.
- Au plus fort de la pandémie,
la partisanerie n'existe plus,
vite ses droits durant
l'année préélectorale.
François Legault est associé
à la Grande Noirceur.
de Maurice Duplessis.
- L'ancien leader iaiaiant
Gabriel Nadeau-Dubois prend
du galon à Québec Solidaire.n ne
de cheffe parlementaire.
François Legault fait
de lui son adversaire.
- M. Nadeau-Dubois
est désespéré.
Il manque d'attention.
- L'attention se
sur la députée Catherine Dorin
au début du atatat, pour son
habillement et son franc-parler.
- Mon en
on a focussé juste là-dessus.
- Unlelelectif parmi les
solidaires, jugé plus radical,
internes. Le parti doitrararappe
pour retrouver l'harmonie.
de Québec Solidaire
- La maison est en ordre.
- Québec Solidaire a pressé
la crise du logement...- - - Ça,
un logement à Montréal?
- ... et l'a talonnéatatatatata.
Québec a interdit l'exploitation
d'hydrocarbures et misé
sur la filière batterie
ou l'énergie verten n n n n n nt
d'exportation d'hydroélectricité
avec l'État de New York.
- L'urgence pragmatique,
c'est ça- Les partis d'oppositin
n'identifient pas seulttt
l'environnement comme
son point faible.
(cris d'enfants)
L'accès aurvrvrvices de garde
en est un autre.
MATHIEU
de la Famille, Québec
- Ç f f fonctionne plus.
- Les 51 000 enfants sur
la liste d'attente obligent
plus d'énergie sur les CPE
que leteteternelles 4 ans,
qui sont finalement plus
difficiles que prévu à réaliser.
tititititititititititititititit.
- Québec a beau bonifierle sala,
abolir les élections scolaires
et transformer les commissions
tout semble éclipsé parles probt
de vétusté des écoles, un enjeu
lui rappellent sans relâche.
CATHERINE FOURNIER
- J'en suis arrivée
ma réflexion que l'avenir
n'était pas au Parti québécois.
- Avec trois députés d d d d d ,
arararti québécois a perdu
son statut de deuxièmeopopopopoe
Fournier, Harold Lebel se fait
arrêter pour agression sexuelle
et Sylvain Roy ne s'entend pas
avec le nouveau chef non élu,mo.
PAUL ST-PIERRE PLAMONDON,
chef du Parti Québécois
- Il y a un seul parti quiususu!
- Un optimisme rabroué par
le ténor Lucien Bouchard,
qui qualifie le PQ
de véhicule usé.
- C'est clair qu'ils seront pas
bien au PQ, on va eee
d'accord avec ça.
- Allez-vous travailler,
M. Legault, eaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaeaes
de la prochaine élection?
- Eutututez, on va voir d'abord
comment M. Trudeau va évoluer.
- Ses relations avec
s s s s s s s s s s s s s s s c
a obtenu la nomination d'un juge
toujours des pouvoirs en matière
d'immigration et des transferts
- C'est sûr...
qu'on a des différends.
- Le premier ministre a aussi
des différends avec sa députée
au Parti conservateur
d'Éric Duhaime.
- Bienvenue dans la famille
conservatrice, Claire!
députée, PCQ, Iberville
- Aujourd'hui, je me sens
délivrée.
- L'ancien animateur de droite
est populaire dans la capitale
nationale, qui attend encore
le troisièEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEEÉ!
- Éric Duhaime se nourrit
du mécontentement. Il milite
pour les libertés individuelles,
qu
antiavortement dans ses rangs.
En 35 ans de métier,
André, l'horloger du parlement,
n'avait jamais vu cinq parti f ,
les temps changent à Qué
- Alors voilà pour la politique,
est-ce que le bilan est bon?
GÉRALD FILLION
- C'est un bilan, je dirai